I think this is one of the cool things
ancient history isn't studied by
Architects they're applying these ideas
and principles to the information that
they have so they're finding some tools
and they're seeing some locks and
they're going okay this is how they
probably chopped up around in their mind
engineering is Limitless come back to
the pyramid and you start to realize
there's so much more involved in this
that there's evidence of this of the
people that build it having knowledge of
the planet the dimensionality of the
earth to a crazy degree if you take the
height of the Great Pyramid you multiply
it by 4200 you get the polar radius of
the Earth if you take the perimeter
length of the Great Pyramid you measure
around the perimeter of it and you
multiply that by 43 200 you get the
equatorial circumference of the earth so
right now we're in the age of Pisces and
in fact there's references in the Bible
about this 2 000 years ago was the age
of Aries the ram so think about another
biblical figure that existed Isaac who
are you Moses as well right he blew the
Rams Horn I wonder if that was him
trying to talk because he had a speech
impediment I wonder if like they thought
it was a ramswarm but he was just like